well nowadays we do use recommendation
system very often for different tasks
and it's very important to make sure
that we know what's going on with the
quality of our recommender system what
is going on with the revenue this is why
today I'm going to share with you some
thoughts on Monitor and recommender
system in
production basically we do use
recommendations like everywhere nowadays
we have a lot of content implemented in
Ecommerce systems like lots of products
and services and we have media systems
where we have quite a lot of content for
users and recommendations helps our
users to find quickly relevant content
right and we do use Commander systems
not only in media and e-commerce but
also from for different products varying
from procurement to manufacturing where
we use recommendations to help us find
what is uh the next best action or what
is the optimal strategy for procurement
right this is why it's pretty well
spreaded so uh the question is is how to
evalate recommendations and basically
pretty often when we use recommender
system we optimize our business process
or technological process one way or
another right and this is why usually we
can follow the money basically for
almost any recommender system and
service which uses recommender system we
can calculate something like total
revenue or average revenue per user
maybe it's average cheick or something
related to money and the good news is
that it's quite convenient and easy to
measure the economic effect from our
recommender system in the online
experiments like abest why so because
basically for online experiments it's
very easy to like split our users or
other objects into two groups where in
one group we do not have our recommender
system in the other group we do have
recommender system and if the
recommender system is the only
difference between a and b segment we
can easily compare the revenue and
attribute the additional economic effect
to our recommender system so it's very
convenient to measure the revenue in
terms of short short-term effect in AB
test but it's not that straightforward
in terms of long-term evaluations right
especially when we deployed our
recommender system to production and
later we want to see how much additional
value how much additional Revenue we are
able to generate with help of our
recommender system in this case have two
main problems first is attribution
problem right because when we already
use our recommender system in production
it's really hard to assign the
particular the exact part of our Revenue
to recommender system right and for the
bugging issues it's quite similar
because let's say we see that our
Revenue dropped and it's revenue from
the whole service right what exactly has
happened is it happened because you have
some data quality issue or maybe it's
because the quality of our
recommendations get worse or maybe it's
just the market itself right so it's
quite hard to debug and connect the
quality of our recommendations to the
revenue itself this is why it's
important to build the whole
observability system to figure out
what's going on with our service and be
able to debug things
faster in terms of 8 recommendations in
Productions I would like to present to
you recommendation metri karch here I
believe it's very import to BU build up
such a system especially if you have
your recommender system already
operating in production because it helps
to quickly observe what's going on and
uh quickly react appropriately to any
issues so first of all we start from the
online business matrics generally it's
something connected to money like like
Revenue average revenue per user Etc
then you can go down to online quality
metrics and the trick here is that we
need to find out some proxy metrics
which are closely connected to our
Revenue metrix but can be easily
calculate in online like clicks views
friends in mindes maybe conversion from
one game level to the other for online
games it's very depend on the problem
statement right and finally when we work
with our uh recommender systems in
offline we can calculate quite a lot of
quality metrics it can be metrics
related to the ranking quality like
recall at topk objects Precision at topk
mean absolute U average Precision at
topk Etc and it can be many Beyond
accuracy metrics like novelty diversity
popularity bias Etc let's take a deeper
look at Sal metrics so first of all
online business metrics this is always a
priority right because that's the kpi
metrix for our service in most cases uh
this metric help us the reflect to the
business impact the best way
unfortunately sometimes it might be
quite hard hard to measure some metrics
such metrics directly this is happens
because let's say we work with the
eCommerce application where our users
can buy some products in this case we
might show some recommendations right
and it's very easy to measure like views
or clicks to recommendations but it's
much harder to like measure the
purchases because sometimes it's took
users like hours or days or our weeks to
decide whether to buy something or not
especially if it's something quite
expensive right so if let's say users
needs like several weeks to decide on
the product and buy it and if you
already have our recommender system in
production you might just miss the
moment when the quality of our
recommender system started to uh really
influence negatively to the revenue
right and if for example user need like
two weeks to uh in average of course to
commit a purchase but after one week the
quality of our recommender system drop
you have no chances to detect it and
react in time right this is why it's
important not only have our online
matric uh I mean business metrix but
also have very good process to um
connect to business Matrix so anyway we
start from the correct uh online
business metric right and to in order to
give to get a complete picture we needs
to add more so the next group is online
quality matrics uh those metrics are
often called proxy metrics because it
help us to detect some issues with the
revenue like metrics faster those
metrics are very Cas specific generally
it can vary from clicks views on Med
content purchases or added to the basket
for e-commerce or some conversions in
gaming maybe even some conversations LS
or maybe invite invitations to friends
in a social network so in order to be
able to come up with the good proxy
matrix it's important to have some
understanding and experience of the
domain area basically those are metrics
which are very easy to calculate
especially in real time because clicks
shows it's something that we can measure
like
directly this is the proxy symptom level
monitoring metrix and this is why we can
easily set up some alerts on such metric
like maybe alerts on the average share
of clicks on recommendation block or
average uh share of conversion from a
level n to level n plus one in online
game
Etc it's very nice to also analyze the
connection between the online business
metrics and such metrics like
correlation in order to be able to set
up the right alert and those metrics are
also very nice for the bagging because
let's say if our Revenue based metrics
like average revenue per user goes down
we can go and analyze clicks and Views
if you have those those metrics already
in our dashboard so that we can faster
figure out what's going
on also there are a bunch of offline
metrics which we generally use in
offline during the models evaluation
process specifically when we train your
models to some experiments or maybe do
cidate selection before the ab test so
that we promote to the ab test the best
option the best metric right but the
good news is that those metrics are also
can be used during the
monitoring um the complication with
those matrics is that generally we are
able to calculate those matrics and use
them properly when we calculate it on
bch of the data because when you
calculate something like Precision at K
or recall at k for individual user it
doesn't really gives us a lot of
insights right so it's better to have a
bunch of users than calculate this
Precision it K or recall it K and then
analyze the values so uh yeah it's hard
to measure those metrics on top of
individual user users uh but it's good
to measure them on top of the batch of
data so uh why not to calculate it in a
batch mode in online like for instance
calculate those metrics every 10 minutes
every hour on daily basis or maybe once
per week right it can be done perfectly
and actually that's very nice help us to
uh with debugging right because we can
always connect our online Matrix with
STS offline Matrix calculated in B and
see what's going on this helps to
connect the model quality itself like
quality of ranking with some proxy
Matrix and online Matrix this is why
it's very important to not only like
monitor those metrics but also make some
additional analysis I would say it's
super important especially if you
automate the way of uh model retraining
and candidate selection I mean if you do
it automatically and you rely on your
offline metric it's essential to know
how exactly those offline metrics
connected to revenue based metrix and
proxy matric because well if you do
candidate selection on top of offline
metric and you are not sure whether
those offline matrics are like even
correlated with online matrics then
what's the point right our idea is to
promote the model which is expected to
be the better one during the ab test and
this is why it's important to make sure
we use the relevant offline Matrix so
that's why I believe that's very
important and uh well I would like to
share metrix can be used in offline mode
because we do quite a lot and uh here I
would like to mention that uh I'm
showing to you the examples of reports
made by evidently open source library
for model monitoring testing and
validation and I'm a maintainer so I'm
not inting that evidently is the only
Library you can use for recommender
system quality estimation but um here
I'm sure what we have this is why I
share it with you so for recommender
system we have quite a lot of metrics
like Precision at K recall at K fscore
and those metrics can be calculated not
only in a monitoring way where you have
new uh evaluation for each new buch of
data but also you can compare the value
of those metric between the reference
data if you have them and the current
data which is quite nice for debugging
because if you have your reference data
where you are happy with the performance
of your recommender system you can
always compare the Precision at ke for
instance between those two bdes of data
and it's my easier to come up with the
conclusion whether you are happy with
the particular value of your metric or
not because you know what is your
Baseline what is your basis for
comparison and well there are quite a
lot of such metrics there are Ela
metrics for ranking like um normalized
discounted communative gain at K mean
reciprocal rank at K heat rate mean
absolute mean average Precision Etc and
it's very nice to like first think
through those metrics and select the
right ones for you because for for
instance if you if you build your
recommend recommendations and you know
that there is one relevant the most
relevant object um among your
recommendations you might want to go to
the heat rate because you want to
calculate how often you cover this the
most relevant object uh in your
recommendations but if you want to like
have the a lot of relevant objects in
the right um let's say in the right
order right with the relevant ranks then
instead of heat rate you might prefer to
use normalized discounted cumulative
gains so it's always good to analyze and
choose among the offline metrics and
select the one which correlates with the
revenue in a best way right also
together with uh the quality based
metrics there are quite a lot of Beyond
accuracy matric like Serendipity novelty
diversity coverage in different biases
and it's also quite good matric because
if you understand how exactly you're
used to command your system in
production you can always find some
correlation between those Beyond
accuracy metric and the revenue based
metrics right and evidently we also have
a lot of Beyond accuracy metrics
implemented so you do not need to
implement them uh those metrics yourself
and well we have diversity which is
basically show how varied are the
recommendations shown to each user and
if you know that your users react best
on diverse recommendations where you
have for example movie from different
categories or products from different
categories it's good to measure this
diversity even in a batch way in online
and have this metric plotted on your
dashboard maybe in a separate top
compared to revenue based metric because
you will be able to quickly switch
between those tops and the bug issues
faster so here is the diversity novelty
how novel are the recommendations
compared to what the user had in the
training set or uh compared to the
interactions previous interactions of
the user there is personalizations so we
can measure the overlap between the
different users recommendation lists
it's also certainity so if you know that
your user prefer to have some surprising
recommendations and you don't want to
recommend the second Harry Potter to the
users who already Sol the first Harry
Potter then Serendipity is your metric
to make sure you do not do that there
are also a lot of biases like price bias
or popularity buys and if you know for
instance then if you start to recommend
a less expensive produ products then
your Revenue goes down then probably the
price buys is something you want to
monitor as well as the popularity buys
if it's if it's the case for um your
system uh I also want to make a short
side note and talk a little bit about
the debugging because quite often if you
see some quality drop in production in
terms of revenue for instance we start
to dig deeper and analyze some proxim
Metric then we go to some gcks views
purchases and and sometimes it's enough
and it helps us to quickly figure out
what's going on with our model but
sometimes it's not and then we go to
offline matric and well it's hard to
find the reason of quality drop quickly
uh for be able to debug and perform
analysis quite fast I suggest you always
have some additional tools under your
sleeve to item level or user level
debugging because it's very very helpful
uh let me um show
an example here so imagine you work with
some movie recommender system in this
case you might create this uh let's say
Avatar users who are not actual users
but you might create users with very
particular properties like for instance
you can uh create or simulate a user who
always like to see let's say uh romantic
movies and other users user who prefer
to see some horror movies right in this
case if you know this property of the
user you can generate like the synthetic
history uh with this popular uh horror
movies for instance and then you can
create some expectations on how the
ideal or good recommendations look for
this synthetic user in this case if you
have a tool which helps you to quickly
observe what is the recommendations
generated for a specific user and in
evidently we have uh this specific
metric which is called uh Rec case table
but it's uh not the topic here of course
you can later figure out I have a
picture from the left hand side right uh
then you can quickly observe what was
recommended in our case the previous
interactions were like iorm movie M uh
Mr Brown movie and like you can see uh
Titanic As Good As It Gets right and uh
in the table nearby we can see the ranks
and the movies we recommend and if you
see something weird here for instance
for user who had quite a lot of renting
comedies during the interactions in the
previous history you suddenly started to
recommend a lot of horror movies then it
can help such such things can help you
to quickly come up with good hypothesis
of what's going on right this is why uh
I believe we shouldn't like hesitate to
analyze even individual users or objects
because well of course we cannot really
um apply the results to the whole uh
generation but uh it helps us to come up
with good hypothesis and even if you do
not have this synthetic Avatar users you
can go for some random users who have a
lot of history right and analyze several
of them so that you can get some
insights and pretty similar things you
can do with the property properties of
the items or users for instance like in
the pictures you can see from the right
part of your screens right in this case
we have a item properties um which is
called crime so basically this is the
Jer equal to crime and uh we have the
data from the reference and the current
batch let's say reference it's
recommendations from the yesterday and
current its recommendations from today
so during the training period we saw
that we had 10% of recommendations where
the Gen was equal to movie so we have
crime equal to one on xaxis and in 90%
cases we did not recommend a movie with
the J equal to Crime right so in 90%
it's not crime so and we see that during
the reference during yesterday we had
like it's almost let's say 177% of
recommendations of crime movie but today
in the current we have 0% of the crime
movies maybe that's the good hint to go
and dig deeper what's going on with our
data processing pipelines right so maybe
it's some um pipelines or some issues of
the data processing so this is why I
believe it's also very important to
start start thinking about how exactly
you're going to do some ad hoc analysis
and prepare some tool or infrastructure
for for doing that well going back to
the metrics in monitoring we can kind of
rank our metrics from the monitoring
issues to the debugging issues and if
you focus more on monitoring and
alerting then you should be implementing
primary business metrics and some online
proxy matric right but if you want to
have like full scale durability and
focus also also on debugging and
Analysis it makes sense to add some
offline Matrix and analyze the
connection between the offline Matrix
and online Matrix why so again it's very
useful for future candidate selection
especially if you will be able to
understand the nuances between the Model
Behavior and the value of your kpi
metric so that you can optimize the
process of selecting the best models for
future experiments and
production uh now let me finally say a
couple of words about full scale machine
learning observability and how it looks
for rec Commander system
particularly basically previously we
discussed two groups of metrics even
three groups of metrics for recommender
system so we discussed business keis and
we discussed online and offline uh proxy
quality metrics right so this part is
already covered but if you take a look
at the whole system where we use our
recommender uh recommender System model
only as a part of the service right for
instance like an e-commerce where we
have the full product the full
marketplace system right and the
recommendations is just a part of it we
need to make sure that the whole system
works this is why together with business
qpi and model quality and relevance we
also needs to implement Software System
Health monitoring I know that it's quite
obvious so it goes without saying but I
want to mention it uh specifically that
well as soon as we promote any service
to production
we need to make sure that it's properly
monitored from the technical point of
view and metrics like dis usage memory
usage response time Etc are covered
covered by alert and uh automation uh
system to react on those
alerts also when we have some Services
which uh relied on the data it's
important also monitor data quality and
integrity right because in most cases if
something is wrong with the data it can
ruin the whole U model right
and here I want to mention data quality
and data drift specifically because uh
if we build our recommender system on
top of quite a lot of different data
like maybe product properties uh maybe
user item mats Matrix etc etc then um we
need to make sure that all this data
looks good right uh by looking good I
mean that we can measure quite a lot of
input data properties like some
descriptive statistics means Medan
standard deviation and check whether we
have like expected values whether we
have some expected values for missing uh
values for different features right
maybe some values for are out of range
for specific features so it's all very
important and we can also add some data
drift metrics as well especially if
you're not sure that our model
extrapolates really well right and if uh
we assume that the shift and the
distribution especially for important
features might like really influence
badly on the quality of our model then
it makes sense to add to data quality
data drift monitoring as well so it's
kind of extra level which stays between
the service Health monitoring and model
quality monitoring quite often
especially if you have pretty complex
pipelines there a lot of steps which
process different types of data coming
from different data sources it makes
sense to monitor data quality because it
helps you to catch data pipeline box
faster and and debug them
properly so uh finally I would like to
sum up what we just discussed here and
well we started from the metrics which
we can use for recommend our system
monitoring and we discussed that it's
quite important to Define this tra uh
Hier hierarchy for our metrics we always
start from the revenue based metrics
because that's the main kpi for our
service and then we go to online quality
metrix because sometimes it's quite hard
to measure Revenue
straightforwardly right um online
quality Matrix is a very nice proxy so
if you know the connection between the
online quality Matrix and business
Matrix we can get right alerts and uh
detect issues faster else it's quite a
good idea to have some offline quality
and Beyond accuracy metric calculated in
a bch mode on the same dashboard because
it will helps us to debug things faster
and well we also discussed that we work
with Production Service which is really
relay on the data so make sure you keep
an eye on your data quality and data
drift make sure you implemented service
Health monitoring and well it's always
have to good some additional tools under
your sleeve in case that there is some
issues and it will help you to do some
object level debugging and feature level
uh debugging because it always help to
detect issues
faster so uh that's all I wanted to
share with you guys and if you have some
comments and questions I'm happy to
discuss
hi Em looks like we have a Q&A um one
question in the
Q&A
cool yes so how how did you historically
tackle issues with business Matrix for
recommending system oh yeah that's a
very good question thank you for raising
it up uh well uh yes the canalization
margin reduction Etc is the very
important problem because let me just
quickly comment so that uh everyone um
understand the point here so quite often
we Face the issues when the recommender
system itself influences the
recommendations we have like we
recommend something then users react and
then we have those data in the next
training data set right or maybe if
previously on our website we had only
search for the products and users use
the search to navigate and find and buy
the relevant products so now we added
the recommendation block and it just
cannibalized some traffic from the
search to recommend your system and it's
quite hard to detect that and yes to
work with such issues uh I suggest to
collect relevant online metrics like
Revenue uh and Etc and then use your um
service logs to calculate different
offline metrics and then analyze the
correlations and different kinds of
connections between those
metrics evidently can help with that
because uh we have a large variety of
offline metrics and a lot of options how
to like parameterize the metrix
calculations it's partially solves that
because you will be able to like analyze
the connection between your online
metrix and this offline metrix so that
you can analyze and uh do candidate
selection better but unfortunately it
doesn't cover like 100% of the issues
because well the way recommender system
influences the um new data can be solved
like in offline right for doing that I
recommend maybe have like at least some
users well sometimes it's quite hard
because well you know it's hard to like
not show recommendations to the
significant bunch of users but sometimes
you can uh do that maybe have very small
amount of users who from time to time
does not receive any recommendations so
that you
can keep tracking them and calculate
metrics on top of those users so that
you can compare uh and have like clean
data feed and maybe you can use multi
multiarm Bandits which provide some
users from time to time with like very
very small probability with like random
recommendations of course it's always
depend on the problem statement and it's
not like a general advice nothing like
this but if your system allows you to do
that you can use multiarm vended system
to like sometimes with some probability
recommend the random products for your
user and by doing by doing that get rid
of the influence of your current
recommander system and calculate some
metrics on top of those
like recommendations without any
infants